are there things that you see in the
united states
in the current culture that's kind of
has
echoes of the same things you saw in
north korea
that that worry you so
much absolutely it's it's uh
it's in america now the meritocracy
doesn't matter right it's evil
the white man's idea of like talking
about
if you're competent enough they say oh
if you're coming from
which white family you are going to be
competent so other people don't have a
chance but
look at asians who came from nothing as
competent and go to like harvard law
school and medical school
so it doesn't almost is like there's no
incentive for you to work hard
anymore in the system right now that is
north korea there's no incentive because
you're born
with your class already so no matter
what you do you can never
so the horrible thing about north korean
system is that
there's nothing even holding mary up so
if you're coming from other cultures
that like make a marker join your royal
family and she became a lawyer you go
up by north korea if someone from high
class is going to marry somebody down
you only go down with them that's how
they prevent
classmates right they that kind of
enforces the separation because there's
a huge disincentives to
go uh to marry to to integrate between
classes
what do you do about this kind of um you
know
especially in universities but in
companies i'm
thinking about starting a company so i'm
looking at this very carefully
there's these ideas of diversity
and and meritocracy that's a tension so
yeah i think there's
there's a big way in which diversity
broadly defined
is not at all in in tension with
meritocracy
so having a variety of people
backgrounds way of thinking all those
kinds of things is a huge benefit to any
uh group but the way diversity is often
defined
is by sort of very crude classes
of people whether it's by skin color or
gender
or or some very kind of large group way
and that that actually does
two things in my mind one it drowns out
real diversity
or not real but the full spectrum of
diversity which is like
within class diversity of like um
are you are you somebody who is
um are you somebody who's exceptionally
good at mathematics are you somebody
who's exceptionally good at psychology
are you good with people are you good
with numbers all that kind of stuff
that i think spans or
intersects in fascinating ways with
these kinds of groups
so that's diversity and then meritocracy
is this
thing that probably the reason i wanted
to move to silicon valley and the reason
i didn't is like
having a fire to change the world within
you like
meritocracy is like i want to be the
best in the world at this
and i will strive and work hard not
stepping on others but like
in purely within yourself be the best
version of yourself
that that idea is um
in some ways being not celebrated
or demonized is it literally
meritocracy is being demonized right now
in america
working hard is a symbol of you
coming from some established family yeah
the fact that you celebrate
accomplishment hard work is a sign of
your
patriarchy whatever thing they call
right
and they wouldn't abolish that they
they wouldn't like stop giving kids
grades
that's what they're already doing right
they want to stop they want
like we should abolish like ssat in
america they take to go to college right
they won't even abolish that yeah some
keep kids have no ability to do math
so why do you have to force them to
learn math and that's what comes with
humans overcome challenges yeah that's
what makes
us special but then like because these
kids coming from this family let's find
a reason why they cannot
and then they don't have to do that
thing but they still deserve the same
job they need to be a lawyer and doctors
yeah and that's like what in north korea
i was like not
there was not even meritocracy to begin
with right you did you born in the same
family the family the blood right
like if one person does something wrong
it's like collective guilt because i
spoke out
three generations of my family got
punished who are left behind
and then in america i see the same thing
like if you're
somehow great great grandfather on the
slave
now you are privileged and you're guilty
because you are
white and geared then but how do you
change your ancestor
how did you have a saying on it and that
is where there's no way out
there's no forgiving there's moving
forward and this current culture in
america now like i remember
at columbia like before class everybody
had to go around of saying
tell us what your pronoun is and
my english my third language i learned
as a thought
even saying he and she i'm confused by
it this is a pure mistake
and they say call me day because i'm
gender fluid basically i can be a girl
but next hour you talk to me i'm a boy
right yeah
and if you don't do it right they like
look at you why are you big at
right it makes me so nervous and this is
where i come to this
is a regression of civilization we are
regressing as a humanity here
like the enlightenment all of those
things made us so much brighter
and looking forward and now we are going
backwards well i think it's
there's a pendulum aspect to it because
it's my it's my hope in terms of
backwards so pendulum goes backwards too
but
it just goes back and forth i think and
then uh
in the long arc of history we're making
progress i think
all of the discussions of diversity and
inclusion and all those kinds of things
i always thought that they're healthy in
a in moderation
right there should be a small part of
the conversation
amongst other things the the natural asp
like it seems that they kind of have
this way of just consuming all
conversations
it's like the meetings like diversity
and inclusion meetings multiply somehow
where it's like the only thing that
you're talking about it's very kind of
absurd and when i look at uh
even at mit it's it's it's a strangely
disproportionate amount of
amount of discussions about that and
also to me as an engineer those
discussions are very frustrating because
they don't seem to actually
do anything no so like they want
to uh bully people
instead of creating systems that fix
define
like definitive problems and
that in itself that kind of bullying
that's the same kind of
thing you saw in terms of mccarthyism in
america
against the communists you certainly saw
that in soviet union
against everybody who's not communist
it's uh it creates
hate not progress
you